und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend wir haben uns alle daran
gewöhnt dass Grenzkontrollen in Europa
eigentlich Geschichte sind von einem
Land ins andere ohne Schlagbaum ohne
Staus ohne neugierige Fragen des Zolls
wir merken die Grenzen oft gar nicht
mehr richtig jetzt läuft allerdings eine
Diskussion auf Hochtouren ob neue
strengere Kontrollen nötig und wirksam
wären um die schleuserkriminalität in
den Griff zu bekommen Deutschland und
seine Migrationspolitik auf der
Tagesordnung ganz oben gleichzeitig geht
beim entscheidenden Thema wer bezahlt
nicht mehr viel die Gespräche zwischen
Bund und Ländern ohne Ergebnis die
Länder verärgert weil der Bund im
kommenden Jahr seine Zuschüsse für
Aufnahme und Versorgung von Flüchtlingen
halbieren will mehr Geld sei nicht da
Klaus Brodbeck jetzt über Standpunkte
der Politik und Aktionen der Polizei
die Polizei kam am frühen Morgen 350
Beamte großrazia hier im
niedersächsischen Stade aber auch in
Hessen Bayern Bremen und NRW wurde
durchsucht fünf mutmaßliche Schleuse
wurden festgenommen mehr als 100 Syrer
soll die Gruppe illegal nach Deutschland
gebracht haben ein Erfolg so die
Innenministerin faserkönig an
Grenzkontrollen zu verstärken teilweise
auch stationär die Schleusen haben noch
mal zugenommen sehr menschenverachtende
Tat wo Menschen eng eingepfercht ohne
Wasser in LKWs über die ganze geschleust
werden und dafür wird das notwendig sein
verstärkt die Grenzkontrollen zu
Tschechien Polen zu machen der
Opposition ist das zu wenig das ist
durchschaubares Wahlkampf
Taktik um in Hessen noch die SPD vor
einem nicht ganz so schlechten Ergebnis
zu retten es ist richtig hier
Grenzkontrollen zu Polen und Tschechien
auch durchzuführen die wir sie zu
Österreich auch kennen aber dies braucht
eine Notifizierung in Brüssel das getan
aber könnte Wochen dauern Faeser will
sich schneller direkt mit Polen und
Tschechien verständigen experten warnen
davor stationäre Grenzkontrollen zu
überschätzen
stationäre ganzkontrollen sind statisch
statische Grenzkontrollen werden
natürlich auch genutzt dann außerhalb
das heißt also links und rechts kann ich
daran vorbeifahren der Grenzkontrolle
ist nicht geholfen weil wir die Schleuse
einfach nicht bekommen in der Ampel
besteht Einigkeit Deutschland alleine
kann das Migrationsproblem nicht lösen
mittelfristig brauchen wir ein
eu-außengrenzenschutz ich sagte vorhin
auf europäischer Ebene könnte dieser
Durchbruch jetzt endlich gelingen morgen
will die Innenministerin die
grenzvereinbarung mit Polen und
Tschechien vorstellen in den Tagen
darauf soll es losgehen
und jetzt in einer Region gerade mal
rund vier Flugstunden von uns entfernt
in der zu light und Elend jetzt auch
noch eine furchtbare Katastrophe kommt
nach neuesten Berichten bis zu 125 tote
hunderte Verletzte weil ein
Treibstofflager explodiert ist wo sich
Menschen auf der Flucht offenbar mit
Benzin eindecken wollten weil sie Hals
über Kopf ihrer Heimat verlassen nur mit
dem was sie am Leibe tragen von den
insgesamt 120.000 armenierinnen und
Armenien die in der Kaukasus Region
Bergkarabach Leben sind in den letzten
Tagen bereits fast ein Viertel nach
Armenien geflohen nachdem das
aserbaidschanische Militär in Karabach
die Kontrolle übernahm und jetzt die
blanke Angst umgeht Sebastian
die Erleichterung ist riesig dieser
Vater hat es geschafft er kann nach
Tagen der Unsicherheit seine Kinder
wieder in den Arm nehmen vor einer
Kamera äußern möchte er sich nach der
Flucht aus Bergkarabach nicht doch
dieses Szene zeigt wie groß die
Anspannung für ihn gewesen sein muss
in Gore ist drängen sich hunderte vor
dem Theater wo sie Erste Hilfe erhalten
alle sind überstürzt geflohen
wir haben nur unsere Dokumente unser
Auto etwas Geschirr und Decken
mitgenommen unser Haus haben wir
zurückgelassen
sind sollen wir etwa getötet werden
sie haben Angst um ihr Leben zu viele
Menschen sind in dem Konflikt schon
gestorben klar ist also bei janische
Soldaten kontrollieren jetzt ihre Heimat
in Bergkarabach die Leiterin der US
entwicklungsbehörde Samantha Power drauf
heute an der Grenze ein und forderte von
Aserbaidschan internationalen
Beobachtern und humanitären
Organisationen Zugang nach Berg Karabach
zu gewähren dort ist die Lage in den
Krankenhäusern nach der Treibstoff
Explosion dramatisch sie kämpfen um das
Leben mehrere hundert schwer verletzter
doch es fehlt dann Verbandsmaterial und
Medikamenten gestern Abend einen Inferno
im Krisengebiet viele Menschen standen
wohl für Benzin an als an
Treibstofflager in Flammen aufging
also bei Jan lies heute das
Internationale Rote Kreuz armenische
Krankenwagen und Helikopter zu den
verletzten der Explosion nach de
panaciert ein Entgegenkommen doch der
Massen Exodus geht weiter über 28.000
Menschen sind in den vergangenen Tagen
geflohen und es werden immer mehr
ja ist das mehr als Flucht ist das
bereits Vertreibung fragen wir an Nina
niedergal sie ist für uns auf der
armenischen Seite der Grenze genannt
Nina es muss ja viel passieren wenn
Menschen alles zurücklassen was treibt
sie aus ihrer Heimat weg was hörst du
von den Menschen dort
die Menschen vertrauen Aserbaidschan
nicht und das liegt vor allem daran dass
die beiden Völker sich bereits in
mehreren Kriegen immer wieder bekämpft
haben das ist die Erklärung die wir hier
immer wieder hören wir haben zum
Beispiel gestern eine Familie
Bach getroffen die berichtet hat sie
haben einen Sohn die Leiche eines Sohnes
ausgegraben um sie hier mit Armeen mit
nach Armenien zu bringen weil sie sagen
sie fürchten das als aserbaidschana die
Gräber schenken könnte das solche Ängste
Realität werden das wissen wir natürlich
nicht aber es gab in der Vergangenheit
immer wieder Menschenrechtsverletzungen
von beiden Seiten also die bergkamer
haben Angst unter anderem Herrschaft
unterdrückt zu werden sie haben Angst
dass sie in ihrer Heimat nicht mehr
sicher sind und deshalb kommen sie zu
Zehntausenden hier nach Armenien
Brücke aus dem Grenzgebiet
so jetzt hier bei uns der Blick auf das
was auch noch wichtig ist mit Johanna
und da schauen wir zuerst auf ein neues
ausrüstungsproblem bei der Bundeswehr
für mehr als eine Milliarde Euro hatte
die neue digitale Funkgeräte gekauft
ohne jedoch zu klären ob und wie sie in
die Fahrzeuge der Bundeswehr eingebaut
werden können die Folge sind
Verzögerungen darüber äußerte sich
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius heute
verärgert und betonte dass der Auftrag
für die Beschaffung vor seiner Amtszeit
erteilt worden sei wie die Integration
in die Fahrzeuge erfolgt hätte damals
geklärt werden müssen
das Bundesverfassungsgericht verhandelt
seit heute über die Frage welche Rechte
biologische Väter haben in dem konkreten
Fall hatte die Mutter ihren neuen
Partner als rechtlichen Vater ihres
Kindes eingetragen der leibliche Vater
beansprucht dies allerdings für sich und
möchte das anteilige Sorgerecht
erkämpfen ein Urteil wird in einigen
Monaten erwartet
seit heute kann eine neue staatliche
KfW-Förderung zum Laden von Elektroautos
mit Solarstrom beantragt werden Zuschuss
wird der Kauf einer neuen Solaranlage in
Kombination mit einer Ladestation und
einem Stromspeicher maximal gibt es
10000 € voraussetzung ist dass ein
Elektroauto bereits vorhanden oder
bestellt ist und dass die Antragsteller
Eigentümer einer Immobilie sind in der
sie selber leben
der flüchtige Ex Wirecard Vorstand Jan
marshalleck soll laut der britischen
Staatsanwaltschaft Teil eines russischen
spionage-netzwerks gewesen sein die
Ermittler werfen marschalek vor nach
seiner Flucht im Sommer 2020 als
Vermittler zwischen Moskau und einer
Gruppe von Bulgaren tätig gewesen zu
sein diese sollen in Großbritannien
Personen beschattet haben auch für
mögliche Entführungen
fehlt noch der Blick auf die
Wetteraussichten morgen gibt es
Nebelfelder im Südosten die sich nur
langsam auflösen spätestens ab dem
Mittag scheint aber die Sonne nur im
Nordwesten bleibt es wolkig 20 bis 27
Grad in den nächsten Tagen setzt sich
das ruhige teils neblige teils sonnige
Wetter fort nur am Freitag wird es im
Norden etwas wechselhaft
so viel von uns in der Kurzversion unser
heute journal Update gibt es um kurz
nach Mitternacht und jetzt viel Spaß
beim Fußball und ihnen einen angenehmen
Abend
[Musik]